and now it's time for bum reviews with
Chester a bar tonight's review How to
Train Your Dragon - oh my god this is
the greatest movie I've ever seen in my
life boilers boiler
here's his kid named backhoe oh excuse
me dear sis kid named backhoe
except he's no longer a kid anymore well
he kind of is he's gone up but he still
has a high-pitched nasally voice that's
still going through puberty like you're
right Norton is there a free because
there's a city vivillon played by Bob
Marley's Despicable Me and he's like I'm
trying to tuck my arms oh I hate our
dragons hey well what are you gonna do
Abed I'm going to conquer the world
so wait you're gonna use the thing you
Val revenge against to go against people
you don't bow revenge against yes that
makes no sense whatsoever
what do you care we have pretty flying
scenes yeah pretty flying teens but
things that he can go and talk to the
bad guy but any comes across his mother
who's looking after all these
uncontrollable fire-breathing Hellspawn
which is what most mothers think they do
anyway but is like why did you leave me
when I was a kid I need friend in
Detroit after they kidnapped me and I
know is your father's prejudiced I
couldn't live in that world you thought
it'd be better parenting to leave me
with a prejudiced barbaric jerk well I
know I couldn't change his mind I get
better parenting to leave me with a
prejudiced barbaric jerk you can't be
mad at me I played my cate blanchett you
cannot make a point chatsberry you're
right let's do some more pretty flying
scenes Oh God yeah pretty flying team
but then the father comes around and
he's like no that I found you my wife
can we be a family when smart yes
everything has changed you changed I
barely ever oh now what what is it it's
the middle of the movie we're all happy
we're a family again somebody's got to
die but reminds me hiccup have I told
you how to be a successful King in case
I die in a dead white carp but then Bob
Marley's Despicable Me comes along and
he's like I have come to kill your alpha
dragon with my alpha dragon wait a
minute
you control an alpha dragon that's right
hell did you do that took me forever to
train a dragon
like my size I am like the size of three
Chrysler buildings how would I even seem
to know that you're training here I sort
of um you know for our film series
called How to Train Your Dragon we don't
really see how you train your dragon'
alright I'll tell you how I did it I
just talked to him with pretty flying
scenes mixed in with pretty battle
scenes oh that makes sense yeah pretty
flying scenes mixed feel the pretty
battle scenes so the ban on vagina kills
a good outfit dragon and now we'll drag
into a controlled by the big man off a
dragon Obama released Despicable Me as I
kill the character we all know it's
going to die not me my father Oh
selected I mean his father now it's okay
I know that you can be a fine king or
you could be the queen no I've been away
for too long you befriended an alpha
dragon I can control a whole bunch of
other dragons yes well I'm sure there's
some nonsense about not loving a woman's
rule or something the women fight right
alongside the men in fact it's
incredible how we're so prejudiced
against dragons and yet women and
homosexuals were okay with homosexuals
rip yeah we made a joke outing the hook
hand guy yo I'm a rainbow Wow mother
you're older wiser and have more
information about dragons why don't you
leave those pictures on the poster mine
to perform scenes yay pretty flying
scenes so convinces toothless not to be
a zombie dragon anymore
zombie dragons is that a thing yet
somebody make that a thing yet and all
the dragons rally around toothless as he
destroys the big bad alpha dragon and
people are like wow look every fire and
defeat the alpha Trion yeah why didn't
he do that before I don't know because
he lacked confidence confidence that
only pretty flying scenes can give him
that's fine we just call this winging
migration to think we didn't try so help
saves the day the family is kind of
reunited and another much better 3d IMAX
film we'll never beat avatar
go blue booties I was a blue pussy once
safe sex kids safe sex so hard to Train
Your Dragon 2 was really awesome though
as an instructional film I felt it could
have been stronger healthier instruct me
how to trace for Dragon I wouldn't be
interested because I've been clean for
several years I'm just really eccentric
this is jittery boom saying
your change can I have a guy are we
having tonight Jay come on we used to
fight him on new name I'm thinking along
the lines of hurt so